hi no leash no problem sit this
three-year-old Labrador knows his way
around but he also knows how to get
himself into trouble he likes to hunt
bunnies unfortunately and so tanker
wears this and it attaches to his
collar the device known as Tractive
follows the dogs every step with a GPS
signal in real time its location sent
via an app to its owner it will track
when he runs what came in handy early
Thursday morning they went outside to do
their business at about 5: in the
morning and all of a sudden disappeared
and I followed him on the tracker but
when tankers suddenly stopped Moren Ward
got in her car thinking he had dropped
his collar that's when she was spotted
by her other dog who let her here to the
Nimo nickel Brothers yard and we went
over to the blue bins first cuz I heard
heard him crying but I couldn't tell
where and then we ultimately found him
inside this giant Beam with no way of
getting him out Ward called 911 the
cranberry volunteer fire department
quickly arrived on scene a little
different than your stereotypical cat in
the tree call over the course of the
next 2 hours the crew got to work but
tanker was just Out Of Reach so we
resorted to cutting the beam open they
really took a lot of care in making sure
he had fresh air and uh got him out
safely tank him out turned around and
licked and licked and licked he was so
happy to see him and so thankful as for
the beam it was custom built and used
only once for the
2201 retrofit of the Lionsgate bridge in
Vancouver but the roughly
$60,000 piece of equipment can be
repaired or replaced here you going to
find it it's clear tanker on the other
hand cannot oh 100% And now thanks to to
this piece of equipment this dog will
have another day I would never have
found him in this beam I believe if it
hadn't been for the device and he came
out glorious Kylie Stanton Global
News